yo
i am so proud of you
do you know what a birthright is peter
[Music]
something that's a part of you like your
name
gardeners of the galaxy what no rocket
so i let groot fill out the paperwork
so we got fine we appear to be 6963
units
short i know we clearly need a plan
if you see anything
we got this
you want monster i'll show you
[Music]
meet your makers we're all professionals
here right
maybe we can work something out
you had one job quilt i did exactly what
the more no killing teammates
i made no such commitment
in less than three cycles the galaxy
cannot be saved we can do this together
[ __ ] great
[Music]
oh no of course i will i'll call you
i'll call you
hi my name is olivier senior producer
here at idos montreal
for the past few years we've had the
privilege to work on our version
of marvel's guardians of the galaxy and
reimagine it into a single player
story driven third person action
adventure game
it's our own fresh take on the guardians
and something that's really unique to
our game is that you get to be
peter quill as star-lord you're
constantly in the middle of the action
as you try to lead this band of misfits
but today i'm really really excited to
have all of you
join us on this journey and you'll hear
more about the game from our team
behind this project right let's do this
i've always loved marvel's cosmic
characters
growing up as a kid i read them enjoyed
them loved them i
had the opportunity to write for marvel
on some of their cosmic titles i went
back with the help of bill roseman the
editor
and kind of cherry-picked characters
from marvel's past
the opportunity here was to build a team
but to make it all underdogs
so that the reader would think oh my
gosh how is this team going to survive
and that became the guardians of the
galaxy comic which we loved working on
i remember the first time that the
marvel crew came to montreal
we were showing them the design of the
characters how they would look
and they stayed silent i don't know if
it's a minute but in my head it was a
minute i was like
oh my god like they hate it we realized
how much that marvel
and adults montreal share and have in
common and
that we knew the guardians were in
perfect hands
looking at the samples that bardots were
kind enough to show me and i think he's
fantastic
and absolutely in the spirit of what
these characters are what makes the
gameplay experience unique to me
is no matter in what phase of the game
you are whether you're an exploration
or you're fighting the guardians are
constantly around you and you never feel
alone while you're the leader the
guardians will also
challenge you and make decisions on
their own and you will have to adapt to
it you are
literally part of the guardians of the
galaxy the decisions you'll make will
have
light-hearted to hunting repercussions
and the game will react to what you do
and say the more no killing teammates
that's who
it's literally in your contract i made
no such commitment
you are playing as star-lord and you're
using your blasters and you're using
your jet boots
star-lord is really empowering he's very
agile on the battlefield
he can slide and over with his jet boots
of course he has his elemental blasters
that have different powers as well
and on top of all of this he can use the
unique abilities of his guardians
we're not pirates we're legally
incorporated heroes for hire
gardeners of the galaxy what no
the story is about a group of misfits
the guardians
in our world they've been together for
less than a year
they create something on a small scale
that looks insignificant and as they
progress through the story they discover
that they created
something really big that threatens the
galaxy there are a lot of
very interesting villains in the marvel
franchise
and when you're starting to work on a
story like this you get to get your pick
of which ones will make the best for
this story
that gives us the opportunity to bring
in some that are well known
but some that are also not all that well
known
[Music]
what otto's is getting so right about
them is
capturing what it's like to be a misfit
family you're also bringing an amazing
imagination to it you're going to see
planets and
characters that are going to blow your
mind interpreting it in its own way i
think makes it
feel incredibly fresh and exciting it's
not a matter of trying to replicate the
comic
or trying to replicate the film it's
trying to take the medium you're working
in
and make the best version of guardians
out of that
they made it fun they made it rock and
roll they delivered everything you would
want
in a guardians game
[Music]
man
37 units we appear to be 6963 units
short if we intend to keep our ship
peter quill i know
i know we clearly need a plan what about
selling gamora's crap
what oh come on you've been hoarding
them stupid knickknacks ever since you
first joined us i mean
don't tell me they ain't worth nothing
quarantine zone was always
i think we should hear our group for
once
you know the only problem with your plan
is that lady hellbender
only buys monsters and you are not a
monster
groot are you really offering to no no
he is not offering that okay it could
work
so gru i guess we could bust him out
after absurd
lady hellbender seeks the monster within
the small ugly one is clearly the
correct choice
he's cruel sadistic and his soul is
filthy and filled with rage
i vote we saw groot i honestly think
lady hellbender will go for it yeah well
i vote for not i also vote for the
creepy little beasts
two votes each peter
well rocket's definitely scarier on the
inside he's unstable and vicious and
totally oblivious to the needs of others
okay we uh we get it
all right let's do this let's go sell a
monster
we're not seriously flying into them you
see the weather patterns of secondary
are tied to the temperament of this
ruler
that's not how women work or whether
you're flying the wrong way yeah he's
not flying at all
guys relax just one minor
adjustment i ever mentioned how much i
hate brain
hellbender's castle isn't even that far
that is not a castle it is an
impregnable fortress
so how do we impregnate it
let's just get closer we'll figure it
out on the way
there is nothing to figure out as beast
merchants we will easily gain access to
lady hellbender
good we've already got a beast all
that's left is the merchant part the
thing i put on my official merchant
costume
there is no such thing
right the fact you ain't sure don't vote
so good
whoa that is some really crazy lightning
out there
never seen anything like it
meteorological suicide is what it is
hey is my jacket all right at least you
got a jacket
some of us are soaking here less whining
more
walking hey storm lord we ain't
seriously walking through this
it'll take forever in this storm stop
complaining
the hardship will strengthen your
spirits i face more than enough hardship
thank you very much
you are welcome people one we got this
this don't fall and we'll be fine
[Music]
everyone okay
we should have gone to machu 4
i would be wary uh you know what i
survived freaking half world
[ __ ] scared us it's not alone
get ready
what are these things
shoot first questions later drop
[Music]
it's about to be an endangered
i am eager to experience lady
hellbender's legendary menagerie
should we ask them for directions i'm
thinking maybe they are directions
oh like a signpost or something i'm not
saying it's an arrow with the word
fortress on it
but statues suggest civilization and the
only settlement i saw when we were
topside that's
lady hellbender's fortress dead end
that's just great it's a retractable
bridge they use them at the prison i was
in
too bad the controls are on the other
side of the giant chasm
what do you not have time to dawl in
this jungle i shall hurl the creature
over the chasm so he might activate the
bridge i
may activate a hole through your face
put me down it'll be
fine just curl up in a ball what drax
throw him no very well peter it's okay
he'll land on his feet
i guess that only applies to cats you
sons are sharks skutt busting i am not
familiar with these words order the
beast to do its job [ __ ] it
come on man fast face fix the bridge and
we'll raise your cup by 5
i want 10. okay deal
thanks for the bridge rocket if you even
think you're pulling back
again hear that ah guys
i got it
these creatures
we've got the numbers
is anything on this planet not trying to
kill us
guys huddle up
don't get too close to that map
this guy barely feels it
that is definitely my top 10 fortresses
peter aren't you forgetting something
oh right the cage
the point of even getting the flark was
looking like mean business
all right rocket time to put on your
monster face i only got one face quill
are you sure about this peter look at
him
you better have one hell of a sales
pitch
maybe gamora is right we should try
selling groot instead
this is an affront to democracy i just
think that
we might need rocket on the outside for
this one
yeah we noticed
you want to make that call then you
better not mess this up
you hang tight there bud when the time
comes i'll get you out of there
rocket style if i got it
what are you doing
[Music]
who's the monster now
[Music]
guardians of the galaxy
how many times do i have to kill you
the audacity that you
thought you could rob me
dweller feast upon them
[Music]
now we're going to revisit two iconic
brands that are